das geben das Thema Flüchtlinge um das
Thema es gab heute einen großen Knatsch
ein Knatsch bei den
ampelkoalitionsverhandlungen es geht um
das Thema
asylbewerberleistungen ein ganz
sperriges Wort aber dahinter verbirgt
sich viel es geht um die Frage wie
sollen Asylbewerber künftig in
Deutschland behandelt werden welche
Leistungen bekommen sie auf was für
Leistungen haben sie ein Anrecht und er
möchten die Grünen einen deutlichen
Verbesserung sie möchten dieses Gesetz
abschaffen und Sie möchten Asylbewerber
quasi den Bundesbürgern direkt
gleichstellen das hat für Empörung
gesorgt unter anderem bei der FDP und
jetzt ist die große Frage wie umgehen
denn wir sehen ja ohnehin deutschland
ist ein Land das ein Magnet ist für
Menschen die aus anderen Ländern zu uns
kommen wollen die hier leben wollen die
hier ein Asylantrag stellen und deswegen
mein Appell das
Asylbewerberleistungsgesetz muss bleiben
es darf keine Verbesserung geben für die
Asylbewerber die ohnehin hier viele
viele Leistungen bekommen wir brauchen
in Deutschland diesbezüglich keine
Änderung stoppt die Grünen Pläne aber
Jan also klar wir wollen jetzt keinen
Magnet werden aber wir sind doch ein
Magnet vor allem weil es den Menschen in
anderen europäischen Ländern schlechter
geht da verstehe ich schon die Grünen
die sagen warum müssen wir uns jetzt in
nach dem Griechen nach den Rumänen nach
dem Bulgaren ausrichten oder nach denen
die jetzt abschiebellager errichten wo
es drin schimmelt wo die Toiletten
schmutzig sind also müsste haben wir
nicht die Aufgabe und selbst nach dem
eigenen Standards genau
um etwas abzusenken das ist richtig da
hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht ja auch
gesagt dass es gar nicht möglich es gibt
ein Existenzminimum das muss auch hier
in Deutschland gelten es geht eher darum
noch was drauf zu satteln also zum
Beispiel 200.000 abgelehnte Asylbewerber
aber dann hier einfach die bisher
geduldet werden im Land zu belassen ihn
quasi einen richtigen Aufenthaltsstatus
zu geben es geht darum dass Asylbewerber
künftig auch schneller eingebürgert
werden können dass sie vom ersten Tag an
wo sie hier sind bereits den kompletten
Rundumschutz bei Gesundheit bei
Sozialleistungen erhalten um diese
Punkte geht es und das sollten wir
Menschen nicht schneller Bürgern die
sich integrieren können es geht am Ende
geht es ja auch eine Sogwirkung also
eine Sogwirkung nach Deutschland wir
stellen fest diese Sogwirkung gibt es
bereits und warum soll man diese
Sogwirkung durch beispielsweise soziale
Leistungen zusätzlich verbessern ist das
ein Punkt den die CDU genauso sieht wie
die Grünen möglicherweise also dass sie
sagt da muss noch drauf gesattelt werden
nein das sieht die CDU komplett anders
ich bin froh dass die FDP heute auf Bord
gemacht hat wir müssen doch schauen wir
sehen dann die ganzen Asylpolitik des
Versagen der Europäischen Union das war
keine Sache der Nationalstaaten die
Frage allein zu klären dass wir diese
unterschiedlichen Standards haben liegt
doch daran dass jedes Land für sich die
Entscheidung trifft auch nach dem
Maßstäben der Rechtsprechung an die
Europäische Union die eigentlich
zuständig ist ihre Außengrenzen zu
schützen Ihre Abkommen einzuhalten dass
sie völlig versagt und das schon seit
einigen Jahren und das ist das
verheerende Situation wenn die
ampelkoration was machen will dann muss
ihre Stimme in Europa erheben und muss
dafür sorgen dass die Europäische Union
endlich in einheitliches Asylrecht auf
dem Weg bringt begleichen Standards und
gleichen Regeln für alle aber das Partei
ist doch seit Jahren an macht ihre
Partei stellt doch stellt doch immer
soweit ich weiß das Bundeskanzleramt
warum haben Sie sich denn nicht mal
engagiert den letzten fünf sechs Jahren
damit die EU das hinkriegt dass auch
immer leicht das auf die EU nach Brüssel
zu schieben aber
die Kanzlerin hat ja zurecht die letzten
Jahre sich sehr intensiv bemüht also sie
hatten auch Grenzen gesehen in der
Europäischen Union auch jetzt zuletzt
beim Gipfel wo im keine Einigung in
diesen Fragen erzielt werden kann aus
muss das Bestreben jeder deutschen
Bundesregierung sein egal ob CDU geführt
oder künftig Ampel geführt dass diese
Aufgabe ob wir schon Union gelöst wird
sonst geht das nicht auf wenn wir
tatsächlich hier an unseren weiteren
Standards noch mehr zur Einladung
umfunktionieren dann belasten wir
erstens die Aufnahme Länder an den
europäischen Außengrenzen die markieren
ja zu Recht ihre Probleme weil sie sagen
ihr löst nicht die kommen alle zu uns
plötzlich haben wir die Belastung und
deswegen ist die solidarische Leistung
in Deutschland auch die den anderen an
den Außengrenzen zu helfen indem wir
nicht weiter an unseren Gesetzen herum
werfen es wird genug getan an den
Außengrenzen
was soll denn da getan werden wollen wir
das da Zäune und Mauern gebaut werden
wollen wir das da Militär aufgefahren
wird wollen wir dass die Grenzen die
wenn man sie die ganze Ostgrenze der EU
betrachtet Tausende von Kilometern lang
ist von Militär bewacht wird das kann
nicht die Lösung sein die Lösung sind
politische Mittel und was die Ostgrenze
angeht muss man dann mit Moskau reden
das ist keine Frage von Minsk sondern
von Moskau also nicht von Weißrussland
sondern von Russland und Putin das
klappt das haben wir gesehen
beispielsweise in Sachen Ukraine also
das ist ja natürlich wunderbar wenn man
wenn man
jetzt ich weiß in wievielten Jahr die
Wirtschaftssanktionen gegen Russland
aufrechterhält in der Fiktion dass
jemals die Krim wieder zurückgegeben
würde dann hat man natürlich keine oder
nur eine schmale Gesprächsgrundlage da
muss man mal grundsätzlich Bilanz ziehen
über die deutsch-russischen Beziehungen
unter die europäische russischen
Beziehungen ich will nur zur Frage
Aufnahme von Flüchtlingen sagen der
Schwerpunkt ist ja ganz anderer muss ein
ganz anderer sein in den nächsten
momentan dieses Land braucht
Arbeitskräfte aus dem Ausland und zwar
sehr viele die Bundesanstalt für Arbeit
spricht von 400.000 pro Jahr die
zuwandern müssen da muss man da haben
sie völlig Recht ich habe hier doch da
muss man diejenigen übernehmen die hier
mit geduldigten Status Leben und das
schon erfüllen die Bedingungen die haben
ja arbeiten
wie kriegt man andere Leute rein und da
war Deutschland immer zu pingelig und
hat nicht genug Angebote gemacht und die
Leute schlecht behandelt wie ist das ich
glaube das ist kein Problem was wir
jetzt in der letzten Jahren erst seit
2015 haben das ganze haben wir seit dem
60ern dass wir einfach arbeitsstops
verhängen die Leute nicht integrieren
lassen nicht arbeiten lassen und das
muss aufhören weil ansonsten fördern wir
auch hier wieder nur an den zwei
Klassengesellschaft die die meiner
Meinung nach gar nicht mehr contemporär
oder gegenwärtig herrschen muss ich bin
da sehr bei Herrn piathoff wenn wir
sagen wir dürfen die Leute auch jetzt
gleich immigrieren hierher und die haben
dann einen vollständigen sozialen Status
können sich beliebig neuen Berufen
Orient das sollte die Maxime sein und
ich glaube die Problematik mit Grenzen
mit Militär oder mit Polizeigewalt
schützen das haben wir während der
corona-krise an der bayerischen Grenze
gesehen das hat einfach nicht
funktioniert weil wir Wanderbewegung
alltäglich haben
Flüchtlingspolitik wir brauchen
Zuwanderungen Arbeitsmarkt mit
Fachkräften ja ganz klar eine
Flüchtlinge genau zweiter Punkt ist wir
müssen uns um die kümmern die schon
lange da sind die die Voraussetzung
erfüllen das ist sozusagen dieser
Spurwechsel Debatte die unterschiedlich
geführt wird ich bin eher dafür in
meiner parteis noch welche dagegen aber
ich finde deine sozusagen
Rechtssicherheit zu schaffen in den
Leuten auch eine Perspektive sie geben
Sie zweite Punkt dritte Punkt ist wir
wissen klares Asylrecht haben jeder hat
einen Anspruch dass ein Asylverfahren
geprüft wird aber eben das ist geprüft
wird und das heißt sind auch wenn
abgelehnt wird wird abgeschoben und der
straffällig wird wird abgeschoben und
werden Anspruch aus syrisch der muss
dann schnell integriert werden der muss
sprachfähig gemacht werden da muss auf
den Arbeitsmarkt integriert werden dann
muss die Möglichkeiten haben sich hier
und unsere Gesellschaft auch einzufinden
und dann kommt dazu dass wir eben auch
schauen müssen was machen wir denen die
gar nicht integrationswillig sind in
Thüringen ist ja gerade aktuell dieser
Fall aufgekommen das sind afghanische
Flüchtling eine ganze Kirche leer
geräumt hat weil er mit dem christlichen
Glauben nichts anfangen kann ist in die
Kirche gegangen halt alles ausgeräumt
und der Fahrer stand da und hat
geschockt was da passiert ist ich glaube
diese Dinge muss man alle einordnen wenn
man das ordentlich macht dann gibt's
auch Verständnis bei den Leuten aber
genau es ist der Punkt glaube ich Herr
moring den sie auch machen diese
Unterscheidung über das Asylrecht und
das Recht auf Asyl für politische folgte
über das wird ja gar nicht debattiert
das steht außer Frage es geht eigentlich
um den Fall des Zuzugs von Menschen die
hierher kommen wollen weil sie sich hier
mehr Hoffnung auf ein besseres Leben
erwarten das ist der
migrationrecht darf es nicht gehen
wir in der Tat dann etwas zwei jene die
den Arbeitsmarkt möglicherweise die für
den Arbeitsmarkt vielleicht gar nicht
verfügbar sind bzw gar nichts bringen
das ist ja ein dritter Punkt zu sagen
wir haben beispielsweise ein
Punktesystem und das wollen die Grünen
auch und die FDP auch da kann man
sicherlich sehr eng gilt auch dann
positiv darüber reden also dass man sich
aussucht wir wollen den Zahnarzt wir
brauchen den Bauarbeiter den
IT-Experten so das aber ein anders die
Locke ich auch nicht mit einem guten
Sozialsystem automatisch sondern die
Locke ich dann mit einem guten Job und
mit guten Löhnen aber hier geht es um
den anderen Punkt hier geht es darum
eigentlich eher das Signal zu senden
kommt doch an und wir wissen auch gibt
eine große Studie der US-Universität
Princeton die ganz da herausgefunden hat
das ist eine Sogwirkung natürlich gibt
wenn man die Sozialleistungen zu stark
hochschraubt also das ist ein klarer
Punkt und hier versuchen die Grünen
offenbar in diese Richtung vermischt
sich im Moment sehr viel was die
Zuwanderung über die Ostgrenzen angeht
es kommen Afghanen die kommen nicht aus
wirtschaftlichen Gründen sondern die
fliehen vor den Taliban die allermeisten
jedenfalls dann kommen Iraker
junge Männer überwiegend die aus nach
meiner Wahrnehmung aus wirtschaftlichen
Gründen kommen denn im Irak gibt es
keinen Bürgerkrieg mehr es gibt also
keinen richtigen Druck zu fliehen und in
Syrien ist es auch eine Frage ob es da
noch einen solchen bürgerkriegsdruck
mehr Leute zwingt zu fliehen da bin ich
aber vorsichtig weil da wütet der
Geheimdienst da ist das Regime hinterher
da kann ich mir gut vorstellen dass
Leute noch aus politischer not fliehen
ich finde es ist jetzt mal Zeit wenn so
eine neue Regierung ins Amt kommt dass
Sie ein paar neue Instrumente überlegt
wie man
ausgebildete Menschen aus dem Ausland
nach Deutschland holt die hier gebraucht
werden in der Wirtschaft und wie man mit
denen die einen duldungsstatus haben mal
einen Strich drunter zieht und
diejenigen die man hier behalten will
weil sie hier arbeiten sich integriert
haben ausgebildet in den Job haben die
lässt man hier und die anderen die das
nicht sind müssen das Land wieder
verlassen und dann kann man auf einer
neuen Grundlage diskutieren